JEZ FLETCHER: Good afternoon
everyone.
Welcome to this talk,
which we've entitled
Maps API Best Practices.
SUZANNA RUUB: Or How
To Be Awesome.
JEZ FLETCHER: My name's
Jez Fletcher.
I'm a software engineer
on the Google Maps
API based in Sydney.
SUZANNA RUUB: And I'm Suzanna
Ruub, also a software engineer
on the Maps API team
in Sydney.
JEZ FLETCHER: So I want
to give you a brief
overview of our talk.
We've broken it up into
three sections.
The first section we've
entitled Be Smart.
And this is some general
development tips, some good
tools that you can use to make
your programming really robust
with the Maps API.
SUZANNA RUUB: And the next part,
we're going to talk to
you about how to be savvy, how
to use some interesting
features to solve problems
in your application.
JEZ FLETCHER: And the last
section-- and this is the
section I'm personally
really excited about.
Are you excited about
it too, Suzanna?
SUZANNA RUUB: I'm
very excited.
JEZ FLETCHER: This
is the section
we've entitled Be Awesome.
And this is where we're going
to take you through some
advanced features of the API
and using some different
services in concert to create
some really powerful
applications.
All right, so let's get
started with Be Smart.
And we're going to start this
in kind of an odd place
because we're going to tell
you first when maybe you
shouldn't be using
the Maps API.
And that's an odd thing to start
off with in a talk about
the Maps API.
So here what I want to do is I
want to add a marker to the
map showing where my favorite
beer store in Australia is.
And to do this, I've loaded
up the entire
JavaScript of the Maps API.
We've got a pannable map.
It's got Street View.
It's a big download, and all I
really wanted to do was to put
a marker on the map.
And maybe this is overkill.
This might be a situation where
the right tool for the
job is actually the
Static Maps API.
And you can see here in this
example, we've got just a
static image of Bridge Road in
Richmond, which is where Slow
Beer, my favorite
beer store, is.
And it's just got a
marker on the map.
And this is really simple
to do in Static Maps.
And this is just a single URL
that you embed in your web
page and it returns an image.
But you might say to me,
well, I'm not just
going to Slow Beer.
I want to go on a bit
of a beer crawl.
I want to go to my favorite
pub that's near there.
I want to go to the Mountain
Goat Brewery which is nearby.
And I want to be able to show
my friends the path that you
can take to walk between
the three.
And the good news is
the Static Maps API
allows for this too.
It actually has a lot of visual
elements that you can
add to the map.
So in this case, you can see
that we've got different
colored markers with different
labels on them.
And we've got a polyline showing
the path that you can
take to go to all three
of these great
beer places in Melbourne.
So to do this, it's
really simple.
The key parts here, we've got
the three different markers
with the different colors and
the different labels.
And we've got the path,
which sets the route
we're going to take.
SUZANNA RUUB: Now Jez and his
friends are wandering around
Melbourne all carrying
their smart phones.
And as smart phones are getting
smarter, they also are
having higher resolution
displays.
And with this, when an image is
displayed, they upscale it
in order to fill the device.
And so the Static Maps API
supports high resolution
imagery as well.
You can supply a scale parameter
to get this image,
which is the same as the one we
saw before, but in higher
resolution.
Which means that when the images
are upscaled, we don't
lose the pixel quality.
We don't get blurry images.
They will still be
crisp and clear.
JEZ FLETCHER: OK.
But let's say I want Street
View imagery.
The door of the Mountain Goat
Brewery is in a sort of
industrial area, and it's just
a roller door, and it doesn't
really look like a place
you can actually
go and get a beer.
So I want to be able to show my
friends well, this is what
it actually looks like.
And this is where you want to
go after you've visited the
Royston Hotel.
So we have a solution
for this as well.
And this the Static
Street View, the
Street View Image API.
And this gives direct access to
the image data from Street
View panoramas.
This is really easy to use.
It's done in a very similar way
to Static Maps, the key
differences being that you
request from Street View
rather than Static Map.
And you also have to set
the orientation.
So you can set a location just
like you do for Static Map.
But you also have the heading,
the pitch, and
the field of view.
Now let's say I have some data
on my server about all of the
breweries in Australia.
And I want to be able to
dynamically load information
about a user's top 10 breweries
and plot them on the
map and do some extra
information.
So there are my top 10 favorite
breweries from Australia.
The naive way of getting this
data dynamically from my
server is to make a bunch of
individual HTTP requests, one
for each of the documents
that I want.
Now this can be something of
a performance hit because
there's overhead involved in
making each HTTP request.
And we can see that if we do a
net trace on one that loads a
whole bunch of small documents,
then we get a net
race like this, and we can
actually harm our performance.
So a better way is to have a
handle that can actually
bundle responses.
And this is something we're
going to hearken back to a
number of times in this talk,
how you can make fewer HTTP
requests to a server.
So in this case, we've got a
handler on our server which
can cope with lists of IDs.
And instead of making one
request, we just concatenate
all of the IDs that we want.
The server will bundle those
documents that we want and
send them back to the client.
This can have significant
improvement in our
performance, but there are some
caveats to doing this.
There are built-in limits to
how long a URL can be.
So if we just naively start
concatenating IDs onto a long
request, then we could come
up against this limit.
We should also keep in mind that
we're going to be getting
much larger responses back
from the server.
And so there's going to be some
processing time required
on the client to
unbundle these.
And of course, there's the
processing time on the server
to bundle these up,
rather than just
blindly serving a file.
So as for everything, this is
something of a trade off.
But you generally find that
having fewer HTTP requests is
a net gain for your
application.
That's a good rule of thumb.
SUZANNA RUUB: Another way to
reduce the number of HTTP
requests that you're making is
with your JavaScript, and to
take many JavaScript files in
which you're developing your
different objects and classes
and compile them together
using the JavaScript
Closure Compiler.
The Closure Compiler
takes a set of
JavaScript files as input.
It then checks them for validity
and outputs more
JavaScript that is a condensed
form of what the input was.
It strips white space, comments,
and unused code.
It can also do semantic and
syntactic error checking
before your code hits the
browser, where the errors that
you get may be fairly
hard to decipher.
It can also provide types
through JS stock type
annotations to provide for
type checking in what is
otherwise a dynamically typed
language and can be difficult
in JavaScript that it's
so dynamic and loose.
It also optionally obfuscates
or minifies your code by
turning long variable names
into short ones.
So let's look at some of the
errors that closure compiler
can help you with before you hit
the browser and what might
have happened if you were
in the browser.
JEZ FLETCHER: Right.
So I've written this
small application.
And I ran it in the browser.
And my app isn't working.
And I got a really obtuse error
message from the browser.
SUZANNA RUUB: So Internet
Explorer has a non-standard
interpretation of
trailing commas.
And if you load something, an
object with a trailing comma
in Internet Explorer, you will
get some random line number
and some unknown error--
very hard to solve
this problem.
But the Closure Compiler will
warn you of this and explain
to you nicely what's going on
and why it should be avoided.
JEZ FLETCHER: OK, great.
So I fixed up my
trailing comma.
But I'm still getting a whole
bunch of errors, Suzanna.
Can't you help me?
SUZANNA RUUB: So the compiler
can also warn
about undefined variables.
So here the parameter two
was spelled t-w-o.
I then used it as t-o-o.
T-o-o is not defined.
Closure Compiler warns me of
that, instead of later getting
just an undefined value
somewhere else down the line,
which would have happened
if I'd been
running this in the browser.
And it warns me that I am using
the this keyword in a
function that has not been
declared a constructor or is
not a prototype method.
So if we fix these up--
JEZ FLETCHER: So I
fixed these up.
I've added the constructor
tag.
I've added some param tags.
But I'm still getting
errors, Suzanna.
SUZANNA RUUB: So now it provides
the very helpful
error that the new keyword is
missing when you call my app.
You cannot instantiate
an object
without the new keyword.
But this is a very common
error that we make.
And often your app will not
throw any errors at all.
It just won't work.
So by running it through the
compiler and being warned that
we haven't called new my app,
we've just called my app, we
saved ourselves a lot of time.
Also, we've declared the
function to have two parameter
types and only passed in one.
JEZ FLETCHER: OK.
So I forgot a parameter.
That's a mistake that
anyone could do.
So I'll add the parameter.
And now we're ready
to go, right?
JEZ FLETCHER: It's still
the wrong type.
It was declared as a number.
So this is how Closure Compiler
enforces type checking.
We said it should be a number.
We passed in a string.
That's bad.
It's warned us.
And again, if this were running
in the browser, we
would see some sort of b does
not support whatever operation
we're trying to perform on it,
instead of just letting us
know where it was exactly that
we passed in the wrong object.
JEZ FLETCHER: OK.
So I fixed this up.
And now finally are
we ready to go?
SUZANNA RUUB: We are.
No more errors and it outputs
a minified version of this
code, stripping all unused
variables and functions.
JEZ FLETCHER: Great.
But I want to use
the Maps API.
That's why I'm here, right?
So why is this code giving
me so many errors?
SUZANNA RUUB: So many errors.
A slew of errors.
JEZ FLETCHER: A slew
of errors.
This is really a
slew of errors.
In fact, next time I'm thinking
of a canonical
example for a slew of errors,
I'm just going to think of
this slide right here.
SUZANNA RUUB: This is
a slew of errors.
So these errors are all saying
that google.maps objects are
not defined.
So you probably can't read
these from where you're
sitting, that's to make
a point that there
are a lot of errors.
JEZ FLETCHER: But believe us
that it's a slew of errors.
SUZANNA RUUB: So it's all
warnings that the objects of
the Maps API are not defined.
So the Closure Compiler
supports
something called externs.
And externs is a file containing
symbol definitions
of things that exist at run
time but you don't have at
compile time in your own code.
Things that exist in third
party libraries.
So the Maps API has an externs
file as do many other
prominent third party
libraries.
So when we download the externs
file from the Closure
Compiler site on Google code and
compile again using those
externs, we get no errors.
And we do get this minified
version of our function.
And you'll note that none of the
Google Maps API properties
have been obfuscated.
Those need to be used in their
full symbols in order to be
recognized by the API.
You can learn more about
the Closure Compile on
developers.google.com.
And there is a web service that
allows you to run your
code through the compiler right
there in the web page.
You won't get all of this neat
error checking that I showed,
so I do recommend downloading
the compiler.jar file and
running it on your desktop.
JEZ FLETCHER: OK.
We're going to talk a little
bit now about testing.
And this is an important part
of any sort of application
development.
But it's something that's often
overlooked in JavaScript
development for the web.
And there's no reason this
should be the case because
there are some great tools out
there for doing testing of
JavaScript.
The two main types of testing
that we do in testing our
JavaScript application, which
is the Maps API, is unit
testing and automated
integration testing.
Now unit testing takes a single
component and tests it
in isolation.
These tests are usually small.
They're very focused.
And they run very quickly.
The advantage of unit tests
is that they allow you to
identify really easily what
part of your code is not
working the way it's
intended to.
The other good thing about unit
tests is that when you're
running a unit test alongside
writing the component itself,
then you're actually the first
user of that component.
And so it gives you a really
good insight into how this
component works, how it's going
to interact with other
things, and the interface that
it actually exposes.
The other side of this is
integration testing.
And this is where you test your
entire application from
end to end in the way that a
user would actually interact
with your application.
And this tests the entire
application.
These tend to be larger tests.
And they often run directly in
a browser, in this case, for
JavaScript.
The other great thing that
integration testing is good
for is checking for
regression bugs.
So one of the first things we do
if we get a bug reported in
the Maps API, the first thing we
do is write an integration
test for that bug.
And then we go in, and we fix
the bug itself, and then
integration test passes.
And now that we've got the
integration test as part of
our test suite, it means that we
shouldn't see that bug come
up again in the same form that
we saw it in that case.
So the two tools, these are
actually the two tools that we
use in the Maps API
to test our code.
And they're both available
as open source libraries.
The first is Google JS Test, and
that's what we use for all
of our unit testing.
And for our integration testing
we use a library
called Puppeteer.
And Puppeteer is really good
because it actually runs your
application in the browser.
And you can actually watch it
as it's running through the
interactions it does with
your application.
And you can also then have a
look at the DOM and interact
with the page.
If there's an error, for
example, you can see exactly
the state that the page was in
when the error occurred.
And they're both available to
download from code.google.com.
SUZANNA RUUB: So this brings us
to some features that you
can use in solving your problems
using the Maps API.
We're going to take these good
maps you have, and we're going
to make them great.
So when Jez drags this marker,
you'll notice that the circle
follows along with it.
And just to point out for a
moment, I want to show our
circle object in the API that is
drawn in geographic space,
which is why gets bigger as
it goes towards the pole.
Just kind of a neat
little feature.
JEZ FLETCHER: Hooray for the
Mercator projection, eh?
SUZANNA RUUB: So that is
an example of key-value
observation.
Key-value observation is when
one object is monitoring a
property of another object and
updating its own state to
reflect that.
So we can implement this marker
and circle following
each other using an event
listener on the marker, adding
a listener to listen to changes
to the marker's
position, and then updating
the circle center to match
that of the marker.
This is a one-way binding.
If the circle changes its
position for whatever reason,
the marker will not
move with it.
So we have in the API something
called MVCObject,
where MVC stands for Model
View Controller.
But it is more generally an
object to help with key-value
observation.
And the MVCObject lets you set
up two-way bindings between
objects with one call.
So here, the circle is binding
its center property to the
marker's position property.
Any time the marker's position
changes, the circle's center
will be that value
and vice versa.
So both the marker and the
circle can be changed, and the
other will update.
This is a fairly
simple example.
But here's something
more complicated.
Here I built a custom map type
control where the custom
control actually shows what the
map is going to look like.
And I've used the Styled
Maps API to do this.
So when a button is clicked,
it updates the map type ID,
which is bound to the map.
So the map and each of the
buttons which are MVCObjects,
share the property
of map type ID.
They know nothing about each
other, but they just share
this one property.
So when the map's map type ID
changes, each button is
notified of that and can
update its style to be
selected or unselected.
And when a button is clicked, it
can update the map type ID,
which is then reflected on the
map and in every other button.
None of the buttons know
about the map.
And the map doesn't know
about the buttons.
It just has one bit of wiring
code that hooks up those
bindings, just like we saw in
the previous example, where
each button is bound to
the map's map type ID.
Now one great advantage of this
is that it's much simpler
to implement than adding a whole
bunch of event listeners
and passing the map around to
all the buttons and having all
these complicated class
interactions.
The other advantage goes back
to the testing that Jez was
talking about.
Using key value observation
in this way, and using the
MVCObject, makes for easier
unit testing since you can
test the map in isolation,
and you can test
the button in isolation.
And the button doesn't need to
know anything about the much
more complicated map object.
It only needs to check that when
it's clicked, it sets the
map type ID.
And that when the map
type ID changes, its
styles reflect that.
JEZ FLETCHER: OK.
So if you've been to any of the
Maps API talks in the last
couple of days, you've
probably seen
this example before.
But that's because this is
something that we really want
to drive home hard.
I put the rhetorical question up
on the slide, who's seen an
address entry form like this?
And the answer, of course, is
everybody because every form
on the web looks like this.
And we don't think this is a
particularly good way of
implementing an address
entry form.
We think this is a lot better,
where we have the autocomplete
widget which allows us to
dynamically predict what
address is being entered
and then get structured
information about this.
So I'm going to type in the
address of the office of
Google Australia in Sydney.
And when we select that,
we get a whole bunch of
information that we can use
to pre-populate this form.
So we've got the street number
and the street name.
We've got all of the information
about the address.
But we also get for free extra
geographical information, such
as the latitude and longitude.
And this is really easy
to implement.
All that needs to be done is
that you need to include the
places library when you
load the Maps API.
And then you can just
instantiate the Google Maps
places autocomplete and pass it
the input element that you
want to turn into an
autocomplete widget.
And then you just listen
to the place change
event on that widget.
And then when a user selects a
particular place, you can get
the structured information
out.
SUZANNA RUUB: So here we see the
autocomplete widget being
used in conjunction
with a map.
Since it gives us that location
data, that lat/long
for the address entered, we can
enter addresses and then
easily plot them on the
map with a marker.
So Jez is going to put in a few
beaches here in Australia.
And I'd like to take this time
to point out that if Jez
always wants to show these same
beaches in Australia, or
he wants to show all the beaches
in Australia, and he's
not looking for user input, then
the autocomplete widget
is not the way to go.
And the Geocoder is
not the way to go,
the client side Geocoder.
In the case that you're showing
the same results over
and over again, you need to
geocode the same objects and
you have a static set of them,
you should use the geocoding
web service, where you make a
request that looks like this.
There are three requests here,
one for each of the beaches.
And it will output JSON.
And you should then take the
lat/long that is returned in
the JSON and cache that in
a spatial data store.
So switching gears away from
geocoding back to our beaches.
You can see these are the same
beaches shown on the map, but
with a slightly more
interesting marker.
This is the iconic surf life
saving flag in Australia that
denotes any beach.
To use these custom images,
we used the custom
marker image class.
And the custom marker image
class allows you to sprite
your images.
Spriting is taking multiple
images and combining it into
one file to, again, reduce
the number of HTTP
requests that we make.
Any time you're going to load
multiple images to be used in
conjunction, they should be
loaded as a sprite, as a
single image.
So here, I've made a sprite
of the beach flag
icon and its shadow.
And to use both parts of this
in the marker, I create two
marker image objects.
The first argument to the marker
image object is just
the URL of this marker.
For spriting, the key arguments
are the second and
third parameters.
The second one is the display
size that you want to show.
So the flag is 20 by 32 pixels,
and its shadow is 35
by 32 pixels.
That's the second parameter.
The third parameter is the
offset of that part of the
image within the greater
image sprite.
So for the flag, it's
up at 0, 0.
And the shadow is at 39 pixels
to the right of that.
So those are specified in the
second and third parameters.
The fourth parameter has nothing
to do with spriting
but tells the marker where
the image should be
positioned to have--
at which point should be
the marker's lat/long.
So here, you want the bottom
left of the flag to be at the
marker's lat/long.
So you specify the zero and then
the left hand corner of
that, which is 32 pixels
for the anchor.
That's the fourth parameter.
Now the marker image
class also allows
for scaling of this.
So we can show this same icon
at three different sizes
without loading extra images.
To scale the icons, we add
a fifth parameter.
And the fifth parameter is the
entire size of the image, so
if it's a sprite, not just the
part you want to show, but the
entire size, after scaling.
So if the image was originally
57 by 34 pixels, we multiply
that by two.
And we need to specify
that in the fifth
parameter to marker image.
You also have to multiply the
display size, the offset, and
the anchor by two.
But the key part is adding
that scaled size.
And the scaled size is not
required if you're
not scaling the image.
JEZ FLETCHER: Another new cool
feature for doing custom
markers that was only
launched at I/O
yesterday is Marker Symbols.
And this allows you to draw
markers dynamically using any
SVG path and have them be more
interactive and more
responsive that you can with
a standard marker image.
There was a great talk yesterday
on this called
Advanced Maps Visualization, and
I encourage you to check
it out on YouTube.
SUZANNA RUUB: So when one image
or one symbol is not
sufficient for showing your
markers, you need to use a
custom overlay.
And a custom overlay lets you
create the DOM structure
yourself and combine elements.
So here I've created some
markers for countries that
combine a flag image and a
label, as well as some shadows
and some pretty CSS.
So to do this, I inherit from
the OverlayView class.
And then I implement
three methods.
I need to implement onadd, which
creates DOM elements and
adds them to the Maps panes.
I then implement the
draw method to
position that overlay.
So I convert the lat/long into
map pixel coordinates using
helper functions provided.
And this function will be
recalled every time we need to
reposition the overlay.
And then the third is just
onremove, where you clean up
everything you did in onadd.
JEZ FLETCHER: OK.
The next thing I wanted to do
is I wanted to show you some
of the beautiful sights of
my hometown of Sydney.
And I thought, well, the best
way of doing this, obviously,
is to use a Street
View panorama.
And so I picked a location in
Sydney that has one of the
best views of Sydney that
I think we have.
And here it is.
Except, that's not it, is it?
That's the side of the
street somewhere.
And probably what I actually
wanted to show you was around
in this direction where we
have the beautiful Sydney
Harbour Bridge, the Sydney
Opera House, and looking
towards the central business
district across the harbor.
Now the problem with what we've
done here is we've just
naively set the location,
but we haven't set the
orientation, the heading of
this street view panorama.
So you can see, when you create
a panorama object, you
pass in panoramaOptions.
So we set the position to be
Sydney Harbour, but we haven't
set the orientation.
So we can improve this by
hard-coding an orientation.
So in this case, we've said, OK,
we want to be looking at
190 degrees because that's the
direction of the CBD from
Kirribilli, where this
panorama is located.
So you can see we've added our
point of view object to our
panorama options, and it takes
our heading that we've
hard-coded.
Now this still isn't a really
great solution because it's
not very dynamic.
And if you need to do this for a
large number of things, then
you're going to have to manually
hard-code each of the
headings that you want.
A better way to do this is
to calculate the heading
automatically.
And so you can see here we've
got two boxes where you can
set your location and what
you want to look at.
And of course these are
autocomplete widgets because
we're entering an address on
the web, and any time we're
entering an address on the web,
we should be using an
autocomplete widget.
So we set the origin to be the
corner of these two streets in
Kirribilli, and we want
to be looking
towards Sydney, the city.
But the advantage of this is
that it's now dynamic.
So if instead we want to look at
Old Mason Street, which is
on the edge of the bay here in
San Francisco, and we want to
be looking at another beautiful
bridge, the Golden
Gate Bridge, then
we can do that.
And we've not had to
calculate anything.
This is all done automatically
for us.
And the way we've done that
is by using the spherical
geometry library, which you can
get with the Maps API by
passing a parameter at load
time, just like you can for
the Places API.
And it has a compute heading
option, which we use here
giving it the origin and
the destination.
And we pass that into our
point of view object.
Now let's say that instead of
looking at something specific,
we just want to be looking
down a road.
And we don't care particularly
what we're looking at, but we
want to be looking down
the road that
we're traveling down.
Now the good thing about the
panorama is that it has a lot
of information about the
panorama surrounding it.
So each panorama object has a
list of links that links to
other panoramas from the
current panorama.
And so we've set our location
here to be Times
Square in New York.
And we've said that we
want to be looking
approximately 180 degrees.
And what this demo is doing is
looking through all the links
from the panorama and finding
the heading which is closest
to our target.
So if we wanted to be looking
north instead, it says, well
the closest heading
is 28 degrees.
And there's a link
off that way.
So we know that we're looking
down the street.
So this is also really simple
to do but quite powerful.
You just have to listen to
the links changed event.
And this will get called any
time a new panorama is loaded.
And once that's loaded, we can
get information about the
links, look through each of
those links for the one that's
closest to our target,
and set the
panorama to be that heading.
SUZANNA RUUB: And now it's time
to show you how to put a
number of these features all
together, or to be awesome.
JEZ FLETCHER: I'm excited
about this section.
Are you excited?
SUZANNA RUUB: I am.
So we've got some help from a
few of our teammates today to
help explain the situations that
we needed to solve and to
build these apps.
JEZ FLETCHER: They've got some
problems, and we thought we
could put the Maps
API into action
to solve these problems.
SUZANNA RUUB: So first we have
our co-worker James.
And he's been kind enough
to join us today.
He has an unusual fear of aliens
and always wears a
tin-foil hat, as you can see.
But sometimes I'm feeling mean,
and I walk around the
office, and I take off
his tin foil hat.
And he gets pretty upset.
JEZ FLETCHER: It's
really cruel.
We've tried to put a stop
to it, but Suzanna,
she can't be helped.
SUZANNA RUUB: Can't help it.
So he thought, well, since I'm
always taking off his hat,
he's going to cover the
roof in tin foil.
And he thought there's probably
other people who have
the same problem where they need
to cover their roofs in
tin foil too.
So he's starting a little
side business for it.
And I felt bad about the hat.
So I built him this application
to help him
estimate the amount of materials
he will need to
cover his customer's roofs.
So I started by giving
him an input field to
put the address in.
And I'm using the autocomplete
widget to do that.
And then we go to
that location.
And you'll note there is no zoom
control on the map, and
that Jez did not need to zoom
in or out to get to this
beautiful picture of our roof
in the Sydney office.
I used the Map Zoom Service to
find the best zoom level, or
the zoom level with
the best satellite
imagery at that location.
So I zoom directly to that spot
and then put the drawing
control from the drawing library
on the map, allowing
Jez, or James later, to outline
the roof and draw a
polygon over that roof.
Then with the path of that
polygon, I can use the
geometry library to compute
the area and compute the
perimeter because he's also
going to do some gutters while
he's up there doing roof work.
So with the places.Autocomplete,
I gave
James a tool to find an
address, then used the
MapZoomService to zoom the map
to the most appropriate level
to show the best imagery, then
added the DrawingManager to
allow him to draw polygons
on the map, and used the
geometric library's computearea
and computelength
functions to measure the
area and length.
I had to do no math.
I had to set up no
click handlers.
It was a very simple application
to write using the
tools of the Maps API.
JEZ FLETCHER: OK.
So the next co-worker that
needs some help is Chris.
And Chris is a bit
of a hipster.
Actually he's a lot of a
hipster, isn't he Suzanna?
He's a lot of a hipster.
And he's just bought a brand
new fixie, only it doesn't
have any breaks yet.
And the problem is that he wants
to know if on his daily
commute there's going to be any
really steep hills that
are going to cause
him problems.
Because he doesn't have brakes,
he's likely to careen
off the road and break
his Ray-Bans or
something like that.
So we built him this app here.
This allows him to enter
the two places that
he wants to go between.
Of course, they use the
autocomplete widget.
And then give him directions
along that path.
And once we've got the path that
the directions are going
to take, we can then use the
elevation service to get the
elevation data for that route.
And we've plotted this here.
So we can see that he goes up
a hill for awhile, but then
it's a pretty gentle trip all
the way down the hill for the
hipster in his hipster
glasses.
So this also leveraged
a number of services
through the Maps API.
So it uses the autocomplete
widget, of course.
It uses the DirectionsService to
get the route and then the
DirectionsRenderer to show
that route on the map.
It also uses the
ElevationService to get the
elevation along the path
we get back from the
DirectionService.
And of course we also use a
custom image to show the
glasses so you can
tell that it's a
hipster who's doing this.
SUZANNA RUUB: And then our
last co-worker who had a
problem, Dave needed to do
some home improvements.
JEZ FLETCHER: He really did.
I've been to his house recently,
and boy, does it
need some home improvement.
SUZANNA RUUB: So he thought on
the way home from work one day
he would stop by Bunnings.
Bunnings is Australia's home
improvement warehouse store.
The thing is, in Sydney, there
are a bunch of Bunnings, and
Dave didn't know which
one to visit.
So we whipped up this
app for him.
Let's see work and his home
out in Balcombe Hills.
And then I use the Place service
to search for all of
the Bunnings that are
in this view port.
So these are all the Bunnings.
And you can see there are a
lot to choose from and a
number of them that look
like they might
be reasonable options.
Now to find the best path, I
could have made a separate
directions service request for
every single Bunnings to find
the distance and duration
it would take
to travel that route.
That's very expensive.
It's bad for the user.
It would take too long.
It's too much data.
Each directions result
is quite large.
It's not an efficient way
to solve this problem.
But there is the distance
matrix service.
And the distance matrix service
takes a set of origins
and a set of destinations and
computes the distance and
duration between each origin
and each destination.
So I set the work and home as
the origins and each of the
Bunnings as the destinations.
Then I computed, using the
result of that, which of these
Bunnings resulted in the
shortest trip between work and
Bunnings and that Bunnings
and home.
Then I fired off that
single request to
the directions service.
And I got back the full driving
directions to plot on
the map and in the panel.
Now both the directions service
and the distance
matrix service provide a number
of options for routing.
So the initial result told
us that the Bunnings near
Chatswood is probably
the best--
or Crows Nest, Chatswood.
JEZ FLETCHER: It's actually
in Artarmon.
I looked it up.
SUZANNA RUUB: It's
in Artarmon.
I can't even say that.
So that's the best route given
that he just wants to drive.
But if you know anything about
Sydney, this route has a bunch
of toll roads on it, and it
would be a very expensive trip
for Dave to get home.
So we can send to both the
distance matrix and directions
service the request
to avoid tolls.
So avoiding tolls takes him
to a North Rocks Bunnings.
And if for whatever reason he
wants to avoid all highways,
it'll send them down this other
road through Parramatta,
going to the Auburn Bunnings.
And here, you can see that he
probably actually has a few
options for the Bunnings
to visit.
But the distance matrix
said this one is best.
And if he's feeling particularly
environmentally
conscious, he might
want to walk.
Even though you'll see the route
takes I think about six
hours, and that doesn't include
the stop at Bunnings.
JEZ FLETCHER: And if you know
Dave, he likes to spend a good
couple of hours at Bunnings.
SUZANNA RUUB: So that might
be a long trip if he
were to walk home.
So to implement this, I used the
PlacesService to get all
the Bunnings in the view port.
I then used the DistanceMatrix
service to get the shortest
route in using only one request,
despite the fact that
there are many Bunnings.
Then I used the
DirectionsService to get the
full details of that routing.
And I used the
DirectionsRenderer to draw
that on the map and
in the panel.
JEZ FLETCHER: OK.
So that's the last
of our demos.
And we just wanted to give you
three key takeaways from this
talk to sort of summarize what
we were talking about.
And the first takeaway we'd
like you to think about is
that you should be following
good programming practices
even when you're in JavaScript
and even when you're just
working with the Maps API.
And we've shown you some cool
tools with the testing open
source libraries that we showed
you and the Closure
Compiler that can help
you do this.
SUZANNA RUUB: And then we want
to encourage you to really
pull in all of your resources.
Use as many features as you can
to enrich your data, to
add context to it, and to create
something that would
have been smart and
make it awesome.
JEZ FLETCHER: Exactly.
When you use features together,
you really get
powerful stuff, don't
you Suzanna?
And the last thing, and you've
probably seen this before, we
want to drive home that every
address field on the web
should use autocomplete.
And you've seen that all the
way through our demos.
Every time we had to enter an
address, we used the auto
complete widget.
And we think this is something
that's not just going to make
your Maps applications better,
we think it's going to make
the web better as a whole.
SUZANNA RUUB: So you can visit
developers.google.com/maps for
more information about all of
the APIs and features that
we've talked about today.
JEZ FLETCHER: And
we'd now like to
throw it open to questions.
So thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
SUZANNA RUUB: And if you have
any questions, please come to
one of the mikes.
AUDIENCE: I've been using the
autocomplete widget for a
couple of projects now.
And one thing that bothers me is
I can't hit enter to select
the first entry in the list.
Is this a feature
that will come?
SUZANNA RUUB: So the issue
tracker is a great place to
file requests like these.
We really do respond to them.
So, yes.
File that in the
issue tracker.
We will take a look at it.
That's a great request.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: I guess it doesn't
matter if I walk
up to the mike now.
We have an application that puts
maps on people's websites
for their business.
And they enter an address.
And we geocode it in the back
end, put the geocoded address
directly into the map code on
the website, and that prevents
us from having to geocode every
page load without doing
any kind of crazy memcache
stuff on the page.
But when we had adopted that
practice, it was expressed to
us that that wasn't necessarily
a good practice
for the reason that the
geocoding gets updated from
time to time.
And we should be most of the
time be using the on page
geocoding, rewriting the
JavaScript of the page.
We chose to go the route that
we went because we have
another UI that users
can then go in and
change their map location.
And since it's already
hard-coded on the page, it's
pretty trivial to hard-code
it to a different address.
Is that still considered
not the best
practice, or has that changed?
SUZANNA RUUB: So the question
is around when is it best
practice to geocode on the page
versus ahead of time and
then hard-code that because
geocodes update.
I would say, so if you have a
bunch of static addresses that
need geocoding, they should be
done ahead of time using the
web service, as you are.
But yes, your cache should be
cleared from time to time to
allow for updates.
So I don't have a recommendation
for what that
timing should be.
If you notice that you're not
getting the address you think
you should, then decrease
your cache time.
JEZ FLETCHER: But this can be
batched, remember, so--
AUDIENCE: This is something that
the page gets generated,
and then unless the user does
something to trigger the page
being regenerated, the map would
not get updated in our
current location.
We do have a mechanism we can
regenerate all the pages
[INAUDIBLE]
SUZANNA RUUB: I would probably
advise regenerating them from
time to time so that you get
updates to the geocodes.
Any other questions?
I think the mikes
are working now.
So you can come up
and use those.
AUDIENCE: I think you kind
of covered this with
the batching API.
But my developers have talked
about the rate limits, and
it's a challenge.
So what's your advice for
dealing with rate limits?
SUZANNA RUUB: So for a
particular service--
I guess it goes for all
services perhaps.
But I can tell you a little more
about what I did in the
Bunnings example around
rate limits.
So you'll notice that
I was toggling
between a bunch of options.
And one thing that I did was
just in the client, after I
made a request, I cached the
request that I made and then
the end directions result.
Because otherwise, it's
rate-limited, and so I can't
make all those requests if you
want to toggle back and forth
across all the options.
So any time you're doing
repeated things, you should
cache in that instance so that
you don't make the same
request again and again.
If it's not a matter of repeated
action and just that
you have more work to do, if
you can front-load some of
that offline and store it in
your own cache, that would be
appropriate for say, geocodes.
Otherwise, wait.
AUDIENCE: I have a
similar problem.
I have about 11,000 static
locations in the United States
and every day about 1,000
dynamic locations.
I'm trying to find the closest
of my static locations for
each dynamic.
Can I use the distance matrix?
SUZANNA RUUB: Distance
matrix has a limit, I
believe, of 10 origins.
It's not quite 10 origins
and 10 destinations--
do you have the exact number?
Yeah, you.
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE]
maximum of 100 elements.
SUZANNA RUUB: OK.
So maximum of 100 elements,
whether that's 10 by 10-- oh,
new answer.
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE]
Maps for Business customers
can do 25 by 25.
SUZANNA RUUB: So Maps for
Business customers can do 25
by 25 or whatever that
multiplies out to be.
And not Maps for Business
customers can get 10 by 10 or
some other configuration
that multiplies to 100.
So is that the answer you
were looking for?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so really for
a large number, like in my
case, you don't really
have a solution then?
SUZANNA RUUB: I would say for
a large company and a large
data set, you should talk
to our sales reps.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: More questions around
unit testing with the
JavaScript API.
I mean there's some DOM
manipulation at first, versus
stuff that you don't have to,
versus maybe unit testing with
events that you could
trigger off a map.
Any more thoughts on is it
possible to do that?
What's the capabilities in depth
more with JavaScript?
SUZANNA RUUB: Let's see.
You may need to ask follow-up
questions if I don't get all
parts of this.
If you use Google JS Test, for
example, it runs not in a
browser at all.
It runs just the JavaScript.
So that's a good tool to use for
testing the functionality
of your class.
You can easily trigger events
with it and listen to events
and test your event handling.
If you want to check things
in the DOM, then Puppeteer
is the way to go.
And you can actually inspect
individual elements
and click on them.
And so you can actually load it
up running the Maps API and
check that the map has loaded
and that you have done the
things to it that
you want to do.
JEZ FLETCHER: I guess another
key thing to say is that if
you follow this sort of testing
structure, then it
actually guides your way to
actually structure your
individual classes as well.
So if you can pull out all of
the functionality that doesn't
have to do with DOM manipulation
into one class,
then you can test that really
easily and really quickly
using Google JS test.
And then if you have the DOM
manipulation in a separate
thing, then you can test that
when you're doing your overall
integration tests in the
browser with Puppeteer.
SUZANNA RUUB: And with that,
keep in mind that you can mock
things in Google JS Test,
meaning you can mock out all
of our classes and just expect
that a map works the way you
think it should, and a
marker works the way
you think it should.
And trust us to have
tested those parts.
And mock those out.
And just check that you're
correctly calling set position
or fit bounds or whatever
it is that you are
calling on the map.
AUDIENCE: Any ways to get help
on mocking the data?
SUZANNA RUUB: So I think the
resources for Google JS Test
will explain how to
create mocks.
And it's actually as simple in
JavaScript as saying, create
mock instance or create
mock function.
And you just pass it the name.
So with externs, using the
externs in combination with
Google JS Test, you should be
able to mock the Maps API
functionality.
AUDIENCE: Hi, at the Federal
Aviation Administration, my
users are either searching for
an airport code or an address.
Could I use the autocomplete
widget to first check if it's
a three-digit airport code,
like SFO, and try and
autocomplete airports that start
with S, and then, if
not, go to the address
suggestions?
SUZANNA RUUB: In the back,
do we have airport
codes in auto complete?
AUDIENCE: It usually works
for airport codes.
But we have really minor
airports that it
doesn't work for.
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE]
SUZANNA RUUB: I think the short
answer here is that
though airports are in
autocomplete, we don't quite
have a way to say restrict
just to airports.
AUDIENCE: I have an internal
list of my airport codes.
Could I point it at my internal
list first, or does
it not allow for that
kind of local data?
SUZANNA RUUB: It doesn't.
You cannot insert things
into the autocomplete.
But go ahead and file feature
requests on the issue tracker.
And talk to Marcello.
Any more questions?
All right, thank
you very much.
And there is a fireside chat
this afternoon at 5:15 if you
have any more questions for
a broader range of people.